[Music]
so we are playing white here this time
let's play e4
it's not been refuted per se but it's
it's not as good as it
used to be really okay so we're going to
play the rye lopez the rye lopez bishop
b5
and he plays knight d4 that is the bird
that's called the bird defense um
now what is the idea of this move well
he's attacking our bishop so obviously
we um we want to take the knight
and what we want to understand here is
that
we don't want to change our strategy
just because he's played a weird line
okay we want to play normally we want to
play like we would normally play and
what does that really mean that means we
simply need to complete our development
so let's castle
and now we have a bit of a problem this
this pawn on d4
is is super annoying so we have
several ways of dealing or trying to
deal with a spun
the first is to go c3 to try to
undermine that pawn
but we actually don't have to do that i
can use that pawn as an asset
what do i mean by that well look at this
bishop for a second guys you see that
it's just like
staring at this pawn so we can use this
pawn
to our advantage as long as we can find
a way to develop this knight we can't go
knight c3 that's
problem of the pawn so could somebody
devise a method of developing the knight
without going c3 and helping him
activate his bishop we can go
d3 and where can we get this knight we
can go to d2
and then we can go to f3 so he goes
queen h4 there are some traps here
that we need to be aware of but um
i think the coast is mostly clear for
now i don't see a reason we
can't go knight two he's not threatening
checkmate or anything of that sort
go c6 and where should we put this
bishop first of all we don't actually
have to move it immediately we have a
intermediate move but we can't move the
bishop where should we put it
well we have a4 and c4 we should
definitely put it to c4 because at least
the bishop is doing something here on a4
it's biting on granite my favorite
expression
now we can complete our maneuver knight
f3 okay
and now um i'm actually gonna do
something that might make
some people roll their eyes so what is
what does black want here
what what does black want
so black wants uh bishop g4 that would
be a very nasty pin
there are several ways that we can go
about preventing this the obvious move
is h3 but
can somebody explain to me why i don't
want to play h3 and could somebody
propose an alternative
this is a case where i'm actually going
to go into an end game something people
think i don't like doing but there is a
time and a place for that
we go knight because h3 creates a hook
and that hook is particularly disastrous
because
his queen is already positioned to
attack us
now very good job you guys we don't take
the queen we have an intermediate move
bishop f7
now we take the queen and we are up upon
he thinks he's won a piece but he hasn't
if we move the knight
he takes the bishop but i've foreseen
this it's okay
we do what we take g8 now i want to make
it clear this position is actually not
that much better for us because he's got
very active development but because it's
an end game
we don't have to worry too much about
the fact that his pieces are active now
he's pinning us
i don't like this pin but at the same
time i don't want to go h3 and lose time
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
move the rook out of the way
if he takes my knight i will explain to
you guys why that's actually not
bad for us at all we are we are better
in this position clearly
he doesn't have enough for the pawn if
he doesn't take the knight then we can
move this knight out of the way
which is exactly what we're going to do
let's move the knight out of the way now
isn't this passive
well there's slightly different rules in
the end game he thinks he's attacking us
but because there are no queens
we don't really have anything to be
afraid of that doesn't mean we need to
we don't have to play actively but we
can kind of
casually develop our pieces without
panicking so let's get this knight to b3
in order to pave the way for the
development of our bishop we're just
developing our pieces here nothing crazy
and uh let's see what he does
so we have a particular idea here
we have a particular idea here what is
this idea can anybody see what we're
kind of threatening
what i'm looking at here ladies and
gentlemen is the bishop this bishop is
um thank you uh great show
yep e5 is the idea this bishop is kind
of passive it doesn't have a lot of
prospects so by playing e5
which we can do right now and that's not
blundering upon
and he thinks it is but if we're very
attentive i've told you guys
many times when the king and the rook
are on the same diagonal we need to be
very attentive to that
and we can exploit that by playing
bishop before he's probably going to
block with his fish in about two seconds
and uh then we need to anticipate a
particular tactical idea
if he blocks with our bishop that bishop
is now the pin piece no
he gives up the exchange well thank you
very much sir
now let's look at this knife for a
second this knight has done its job on
b3
can anybody find for us a good square
for that night where can this night
travel to
bingo and ultimately where can it park
24-hour parking
beautiful look at the square knight e4
it's unassailable he can trade this
bishop for it
but that's good for us let him do it
we're up in exchange
now the win is going to be relatively
simple what we're going to have to do
is we're first going to have to bring
all our pieces in let's not forget to do
that
that means doubling the rooks and now
our plan is going to be to identify a
weakness in his position and attack it
well he's doing a lot of our work for us
now when you're up in exchange you need
to emphasize
why the rooks are good the rooks are
good in an open position so we need to
open up
the position the rooks are not going to
win the game by themselves
so we're now going to have to open up
some lines for the rooks
and our long-term plan is going to be to
infiltrate let's say the seventh rank
and either win a bunch of his pawns or
force the trade of another pair of rooks
something's going to happen now we need
to get a rook to the h file we can't do
that
we need to get our king out of the way
and this is also good because
okay well great he's helping us trade
everything
and now we're going to complete our plan
by getting our rook to the seventh rank
and then we're going to have to do one
more thing in order to win the game
we need to involve the king how do we do
that
how do we make get our king deep into
his position
i'm going to show you guys an even more
elegant plan yeah so g3 or g4
we could have gotten our king through g1
to h2 he's gonna play e4
and i've seen that and then we have a
beautiful right yes
what does white have in this position
the concept of transforming your
advantage
think about it carefully what can we do
rook takes c7 so f4 would be winning
but i want to show you guys a different
kind of win we sacrifice back our
exchange in order to get a pawn end game
the reason we're winning this pawn in
game is because not only are we up a
pawn
but we have a protected past pawn
and we can basically treat this like a
king in pawn end game all we have to do
is get his king
out of e6 he's going to be perpetually
in zugsvan here
he's going to run out of pond moves he's
going to keep pushing his pawns no
problem
and the simplest is to put our pawns out
here as
bumpers to stop his pawns from
progressing further
we want to exhaust his pawn moves once
he exhausts his pawn moves
you you guys will see what happens so
once he exhausts his pawn moves
yeah we don't even have to do anything
but let me take just to accelerate the
process
he's going to be in soog's vong that is
a situation where every single move by
the opponent harms his position in some
way
we have opposition but that's not the
important part he has no choice but to
move his king back why
because his only other pawn move gives
up upon and now how do we exploit
the fact that his king has just moved
away very very simple chess
king to t5 zugsvan comes from the german
word for move
trouble literally that's what my
brother's fiance said she speaks german
now we're going to come around take all
the pawns how do we win this position
uh we don't even need to go around for
this bun no need for that we simply
advance our pawns the only thing we need
to watch for a stalemate
that's why in such positions even when
you're low on time try not to pre-move
now the red carpet has been rolled out
at some point i will do a little lecture
on end games and basic end games
and here we have checkmate in two move
we have a beautiful well not a beautiful
we have a very pretty mate
who can tell me the check made in two
moves who sees it
before i run out of time queen e5 is
move one
and what's the second move don't worry
guys
i've got good internet and
i see checkmate don't worry it was all
under control even if it wasn't made i'd
have enough time to win
watch me jinx in my internet disconnect
i have a problem with att 500 bits thank
you so much
all right um no you guys are great i'm
loving the engagement
no no no this is nothing thank you okay
so let's look at the game that was an
interesting game
so the variation of the rye lopez that
our opponent played is called the bird
it was named after i think harry harry
bird was a
a 19th century player he was very good
and he liked these unorthodox openings
um this move was first played in the
year uh 1848
now the idea of this move the idea of
playing like this
is um is is to stop white's knight from
developing to
c3 right and that's sort of the normal
development square for the night there's
also a little trap here
that a lot of people really really like
and that trap
is um let me actually remember what this
trap is so if white goes d
no if white goes like c3 here black has
queen g5 and this is kind of a fork like
this is a bit of a trappy opening which
is why we castle
and that's the biggest piece of advice i
have to beginners
um which is that like when your opponent
does something weird
your your defaults should be to play in
accordance with basic chess principles
and you're not going to go too wrong if
you do that don't panic when your
opponent does something weird just
try to follow basic principles okay
um so he plays our opponent plays
bishop c5 and just to reiterate we can't
go knight c3 that would blunder the
knight so we have two approaches here we
can go c3
but the reason i didn't like this move
is because
if we then take on d4 and say ah now we
can develop our knight to the good
square
we'll look at this bishop this bishop is
on a great diagonal
it's on an outpost and we're going to
have a very hard time dislodging this
bishop
so instead we find alternate
arrangements we ran an airbnb for that
knight
which is on the city of f3 and we simply
get the knight there on f3 it's also
going to exert pressure on the d4 pawn
queen h4 is not a great move because it
actually helps us get the knight to f3
with tempo
so connor raider asks a good question
don't we want to go f4 yeah f4 would be
fine
jesse good to see you man 20 months f4
uh so an outpost is a square deep in the
enemy's territory
usually which is unassailable by
any pawn so an outpost the key to the
definition of an outpost is that it
cannot be attacked
by any pots the the piece that's
occupying an outpost cannot be attacked
by any pawns
um okay so f4
is a good move but it creates the
potential for one of his pieces
to occupy an outpost which outpost does
this create
and black can eventually try to get one
of his pieces to that outpost
but uh yeah look i mean imagine if his
knight gets to e3 you guys see how
annoying that would be
and he can get that get it there pretty
quickly now i'm not saying that's going
to necessarily happen white can try to
prevent it
but this would create its own problems
this would weaken the king's side
so i'm not saying never create an
outpost for your opponent but when if
you do create an outpost for your
opponent
you have to be extremely careful and you
have to make sure that
uh that your opponent cannot access that
outpost anytime soon if your opponent
can't access that outpost anytime soon
then it's very much justified to
create a weakness or an outpost let me
give you guys
one of my favorite examples i've i've
shown this position on stream before
but um i want to show it again because
of how important this is i call this
in the book that i was working on the
concept of inaccessibility
if a square is inaccessible to one of
your opponent's pieces
then it's fine creating a weakness your
moves don't have to look pretty
you have to be realistic first and
foremost so let me
load up that game if you guys just give
me a moment there we go
so this is the game as you guys can see
between two very strong grand masters
uh sargassian and tomaszewski white is
armenian black is russian one of the
strongest players in russia
2013. this position occurred on the
board
now uh let me cut you guys
through a little bit of the grunt work
material is equal
it's an unremarkable position but what
is going on where is the action
at well looking at this position for a
couple of seconds could somebody tell me
what is white's main plan
in this position you got to put on your
sherlock holmes hat and say well what
has white been doing the last couple of
moves
what has been doing the last couple of
moves well white has been attacking on
the queen side
and white wants to orchestrate the b5
pawn break white wants to go b5 and
crash through on the queen side
but there is a problem with the move b5
black has a counter idea that is
incredibly annoying after black captures
black and strike using a principle that
we just discussed when your opponent
plays on the flank
where do you want to play you want to
play in the center what is that annoying
idea
boom goes the dynamite e5 passes it to
the man and guess what
white has this really really weak pawn
on e3 and if the e file is opened
no there's some unpleasant stuff that
could start happening with white spawns
right that's not something we want to
allow
can white prevent black from playing e5
and is it a good idea to do that
and this is where the really cool thing
happens let me control z a bunch of
times to load
the rest of the game so white can play
what move yes that's what white did
you guys might look at this and say for
a second wait a minute
which incredibly weak square does this
create that's e4
imagine if whites if black's knight got
to e4
that would be the were the freaking most
sexiest outposts of all time this knight
would
make a tinder account and that app would
crash
given the number of matches it would
have from except from other knights i
mean that night is literally
the best night in the history of knights
but the thing is and this is where
inaccessibility comes in that knight has
no way of getting there
because the g5 square is covered by
white spawn and the d6 square the other
freeway is covered by white's other pawn
in order to get to e4 this is like a
math question how many moves
does the knight actually need to get to
e4
in like non-blunder ways one
two three
now you gotta move the king away four
five
you got to move the queen away six seven
and maybe i missed a faster way eight
and by the way when the knight gets to
f6 you could play bishop h4
and and trade it because it can't move
it needs eight moves and that is an
eternity in the in a chess game it needs
eight moves to get to e4 that's crazy
the time that that happens well
uh we're gonna you know earth is gonna
turn into
you know we're all going to die by then
then
the next generation is going to be
inhabiting the earth so
that's an eternity in a chess game and
in that time white's going to attack on
the queen's side
so what happens in the game black
doesn't even try to get the knight to e4
chelsea spaghetti with
five the 220 am hype raising my t
to you now you guys might look at
say okay i get it i get it but what
about the bishop
doesn't f4 lock the bishop on g3
uh and it does but can somebody find
alternate arrangements for the bishop
how is that bishop eventually going to
get into the game
through what avenue bingo
death star absolutely bishop b1 and then
it can either go through a5
or it can go to like square like b4
and actually bishop h4 happens in the
game so he finds an
even different avenue bishop h4 happens
and now the bishop is totally fine
the bishop is at least controlling some
squares but e1 would have also been a
good idea
and uh eventually white won the game now
the game lasted for many more moves
the game was very complicated and i want
to make it clear that this doesn't like
win the game or anything this is a
game between two very strong grand
masters but eventually white won the
game and i think that this was the
critical moment
so inaccessibility is a super super
important concept in a lot of positions
if your opponent can't access the square
don't be afraid to weaken it that would
be
sort of the condensed version of that
advice i can show you
i can show you examples from my games
where i applied that advice
uh sort of word for word
and um just to give you a very simple
illustration of it so this is my game
from 2008 i was 2300
against uh one of my first coaches
actually got trouble really really nice
guy
2000 and this position occurred on the
board
now black has just played the move g5
trying to carve out the e5 square for
his knight this is the concept of
carving out we've talked about it
so if white takes on g5 you might be
like wait a second you win the pawn no
you don't
you don't win the pawn because now the
night is pinned
well by this point i'm higher than my
coach no no you may thank you for the
raid of the party of 38 welcome guys but
what did i do i can block without five
but wait a second i hear you saying
doesn't this now weaken the e5 square
isn't this
doesn't this do black spitting for him
well it does but this square is not very
accessible because i have a knight on f3
that's defending that square and it's
virtually impossible
to um
no nema yeah thank you and it's
virtually impossible to get this knight
out of f3
you can't go g4 because that square is
protected so it's the same principle the
square on e5 is weak
but i don't care about that and what's
good about this move is that his bishop
is now paralyzed it cannot develop
and with that black is just collapsing
here i go h4
and i won the game in a couple of moves
so that's why the move f4
in comparison is less good because here
the square on e3 is very much accessible
to black space so we played knight f3
knight g5 that's the key move right
trading queens stopping him from getting
his bishop to g4
and also this is based on a nice
tactical uh detail which is that we can
make an intermezzo or intermediate move
bishop takes f7
rook takes d1 we're up a pawn and we
don't lose a piece
because the bishop takes g8 why not
bishop takes f7 here because you can
take with the queen
he doesn't have to take with the king i
know what you wanted to do to do there
but
he takes with the queen okay so now
we're up upon
last thing i really want to talk about
because our opponent collapsed very very
quickly
uh bishop takes f3 three wise it's not
dangerous the reason this isn't
dangerous is because the queens have
been traded so
we don't have to worry about our king
being weak in fact
uh you know to the contrary this
actually helps us in a sense we can put
our king on g2
and that king protects f3
and if necessary our pawn could
reposition to f4
where it's very nicely defended by the
bishop so we don't have to worry about
him doing anything attacking winning the
pawn we're still up upon
yes it's not very nice to have this pawn
structure but remember we are up a pawn
so white is still solidly better here so
uh instead he goes g5 we reposition our
knight to b3 so that
uh we don't have to worry about bishop
takes f3 now the key move e5 this one is
the game
noticing that this king and the rook are
on the same diagonal and we are x-raying
his
king so we're combining these two
tactical patterns we could have also it
occurs to me now
just captured the free pawn on d4 that
would have also been possible but
this is more thematic more resilient was
bishop d6 but now we play rook takes c5
check
he can't capture the rook because of the
pin we take his bishop and now
actually a very important move in this
position how do we make sure
that we're going to snag this pawn on d4
yes i was the one i'm that one way
rookie four loose pieces drop off
attacking the rook attacking the pawn
this is a fork we're gonna be up two
pawns and we're gonna win the end game
so
this is easy enough we would have been
winning here the way that he played
though
he just gives up an exchange we get our
knight to a beautiful square i wouldn't
necessarily call this an outpost but
it's sort of a semi-outpost because it's
not in his territory
and now we open up files right we're up
in exchange our rooks need
files in order to show their strength
now our king needs to get into the game
and finally this little tactic rook
takes c7 by the way as i mentioned we
could have gone king ju1 and gotten the
long way this would have been totally
fine because our opponent has no counter
play
okay why not knight takes d4 instead of
bishop before bishop before wins the
exchange
right so or at least it forces a
favorable trade
black cannot make a draw here black is
already losing so
this is a simple tactic winning the end
game why did i take with the f pawn
the reason that i took with the f pawn
is because this would have been winning
but i didn't want to allow him to create
a pass pawn
no magnus could not make a draw against
me in this position
there's nobody not even a computer could
make a draw against me in this position
because it's completely lost
and also you know um you know magnus is
is really good but
uh we uh you know we can i can i can get
him even in
even an unclear position sometimes so
yeah this is winning
magnus would draw against gary that's
for sure geary would draw anybody
in any position okay um so
i'm not going to play the stafford
gambit because and i don't mean to
lecture people but really the
the zen of the speed run is
not to put too much emphasis on opening
traps but rather to work on building
understanding
also i've put a youtube video on
refuting the stafford so i wouldn't be
true to my word
if i were now to double back and play
the staffer but hopefully somebody plays
it against me
and actually we've already gotten one
staffer
okay let's do one or two more games i
need to run to the restroom sorry can
you explain the rucksack well
the thing is if we don't sacrifice the
rook we let him establish
a protected past pawn on e3 we are still
winning here that's
fine but it's annoying and we are
basically liquidating
into a winning pawn end game and the
reason we are winning is because number
one we're up upon
number two this is a protected pass
spawn the best kind of fast pawn
and uh you guys might be wondering well
do i know exactly how i'm going to win
have i calculated all the way to the end
no
this is where pattern recognition comes
in it's not that i've calculated here
it's just that i know this type of
position
because i've had them before and i know
how it's going to go approximately
i know for example that we are going to
win by forcing our opponent into zug's
bomb
it's it's hard for me to explain but
hopefully that kind of makes sense
why did you immediately push it well i
didn't push it immediately i brought my
king in first
and it's not unprotected it's protected
right
think of a protected passpond as being
on a checkpoint you know those video
games where you can reach a checkpoint
you don't want to you want to cross the
level eventually you don't want to be on
that checkpoint forever
but it's good to have that checkpoint
you know you can go back to it you don't
you know
you don't have to worry about the pawn
at least until you push it
does that make sense let's go e4
okay so he plays an alakan we've we've
encountered this once yesterday
and this guy actually plays the main
line now
as i explained yesterday um in in my
discussion of the alkyne it's important
to find a balance
between controlling the center on the
one hand
but not controlling too much of it and
developing your pieces so what we need
to do here let's take on g6
and it's a we don't want to go b4 we
don't want to go a4
we just want to develop all right it's
important to find that balance so that
our center is nicely controlled
in terms of developing to control our
center
where should we put this bishop yeah
royajo you're good
bishop b3 is correct why bishop b3 in
order to reinforce
that pawn on on d4 so that when he plays
bishop g7 knight c6 he's not attacking
it now we had a question earlier
by ryan ellis about when to prevent a
pin
this is a good time to do it um
what should we do if we go knight f3 he
can go bishop g4 how do we prevent that
from happening
and i'll explain after the game why we
want to do this for now i just want
people to tell me how
yeah let's play h3 so we play h3 so that
bishop g4 is not a thing
after the game i'll explain why it's
good this is not a thing okay now we can
develop our bishop
okay he's playing instantly now
do we need to um do we need to do
anything in the center
do we need to go d5 is it a good idea to
go d5 or can we just continue developing
who can so if you count the number of
attackers and defenders we have one two
three
and three attackers we actually don't
need to do anything we can just castle
we don't need to respond to this let him
be the one to worry
about resolving the central tension if
he takes on d4
um okay thank you for the pawn oh he
wants this maybe
he wants maybe f5 but that's not
dangerous okay he just wandered upon you
see what happens when we force him to
resolve the tension okay he develops
with tempo but
uh we can just move our knight back no
problem we are now fully developed
and knight before very clear what his
intentions are he wants to put a knight
on c2
that would not be the end of the world
how can we prevent that from happening
in the first place
uh no need to allow this kind of
annoying idea
so not bishop d3 that would blow under
the bishop but rook c1 if he goes knight
ct we can just take
we get two pieces for a rock now let's
get uh dispose
of this knight with a3 let's get it back
and now here's the thing i mentioned
okay now we just take two pieces for a
rook he does take c4 in the end but
two pieces for a rook in the middle game
is basically total dominance so do we
want to trade
bishop for night here do we want to take
on c4
don't think about the way that i'm
asking that question just think about it
independently of how see you guys learn
this all from high school when a teacher
asks
do you want to do this do you want to do
that it's always no
but i'm not like that okay we actually
do
and the logic is simple look at this
knight it's the only active piece he has
it's annoying it's pressuring our bishop
it's pressuring the pawn
get out of here and now if we look at
the rook that's undefended
i want my knight to get on d5 ah juicy
central square i can't do that
immediately because
he's pinning us can we unpin ourselves
with tempo yes we absolutely can and i
didn't just put it on any square
i put it on a square where it also
pressures that pawn if he brings his
queen out to defend both
he's going to get juiced with knight d5
fossilized i guess is the word 95 anyway
now he's got to bring his king over in
order to prevent the pin or the fork
rather
okay juicers
now
what should we do how do we reinforce
the threat of 97
and it's time for us to deploy one of
our pieces that's already done its job
bishop g5
97 threatens not to win his queen but to
win in exchange
because he'll be able to capture the
knight but will capture the rook and we
will be up a piece in the end
bishop g5 accomplishes another thing
when you make a move and it has a threat
remember to also check what else that
move accomplishes so you don't miss an
opportunity to do something in case he
stops the threat
this bishop also controls the dark
squares around his king
and we can use that to go knight f6
check in case he prevents the other
threat sloppy player thank you and what
would knight f6 chuck accomplish it
would
force the trade of bishops and what kind
of mate do you
immediately think of when the fiancato
bishop disappears from the board
now it's time to borrow my favorite of
the xvc vocabulary the lobster pins
remain
bishop on f6 queen on h6 it can also be
done with a pawn
do you guys see how i'm not actually
calculating any variations
but i've already determined a lot of
stuff about the position that can help
me make decisions it's not all about
he goes there i go here it's also about
making the right observations that can
be just as effective
okay so we're gonna go knight f6 and try
to set that up the lobster pins are made
a very good move for him here would be
rook c1 i'd be impressed if he finds it
let's see and after the game i will
explain why this would be a good move
let's see if he finds it first of all
no okay so rookie six is also good
though so now
um the motivation behind this move is
very clear he wants to attack
the bishop and he does and we need to
move the bishop why not have we
failed in our idea of delivering lobster
mystery not really
right we've still weakened his dark
squares
it's just that we just can't deliver
that specific checkmate so now
let's just very calmly bring our bishop
back to e3
and let's re re-uh structure our
attacking
setup okay so this pawn on d5
immediately catches my eye
because the queen x-rays it if we could
get this rook out of
c4 which we can with the move knight to
d2 we're gonna win that pawn
okay and we can now talk our queen away
on a2 we still
threaten the pawn boom
yes he can win this pawn but that's not
the important part
because guess what look at this queen
remember i said the dark squares around
his king are weak
i hope nobody's forgotten about that
because it's check made in two moves in
in uh two or three moves depending on
where he goes three moves i guess
basically check he can't go here because
of the queen he resigns
because if he brings the king to the e
file this is going to fossil and
fossilize them
just winning a screen with checkmate so
very simple straightforward game
and we didn't do that much calculation
so he played the aloe kind
and it was theory up until like this
point technically rook c1 is the main
move but we decided we played it more
logically h3 and f3 now why is it
important
to go h3 because there is one particular
extenuating
circumstance that makes this a little
bit
annoying for white what does black have
in this position
and it's kind of an annoying idea in the
alkyne specifically yeah he can take on
f3
and that's why like hyper modern
openings are annoying because we have to
be very careful about our center
so because of this specific idea we
could go b3
i hear you guys saying well why can't we
just go b3 then
we can but that would weaken the knight
and the knight is in the crosshairs of
the bishop
i don't like leaving pieces unprotected
like that
uh so you know you know what i mean i
don't want to set him up for some sort
of tactic later
okay so we're developing he goes e5 and
this is what people don't do enough
uh basically doing nothing uh right
rook c1 it's a little complicated it's
like theory
but i guess well basically the the idea
is to go rook c1 and b3 that's the
theory
and b3 is a move that people should
understand by now you're reinforcing the
pawn
but the idea of rook c1 first is
precisely so that the knight on c3 is
protected
so that if the pawn moves from d4 he
won't have bishop take c3 that's
basically the rationale behind it does
that make sense
basically in the 1920s 100 years ago a
group of people
came together across europe
they included a guy named richard retzi
uh they included a guy named diola
breyer from hungary they were from
hungary germany austria
uh and they later came to be known as
the hyper modernists
what did they say they were laughed at
initially they were laughed out of
tournaments they said look
everybody's talking about how you have
to occupy the center with pawns
that's why the king's gambit thank you
zazian yayo
that's why the king's gamut was so
popular because in the 1800s it was all
about controlling the center
with the pawns that was considered to be
the most sacrosanct
the most important chess principle was
that you had to occupy the center of the
ponz
very important the russians said it and
you know the british said it in the
olsen
and then the hypermonitors come along
and they say wait a second i don't think
we need to occupy the center with pawns
let's propose a different way of playing
what we're going to do is we are going
to let people
let our opponents occupy the center with
pawns and then we're going to attack
those pawns from a distance
with our pieces and basically what we're
going to bank on is the fact that they
over extend themselves they won't be
able to support those pawns because
their center is too big the roman empire
is going to start to collapse
and they developed openings like the
modern where you basically provoke your
opponent into grabbing as much of the
center as possible
and then you snipe at that center with
your pieces the king's indian
also part of that category okay
so i don't know if that description
makes sense i'm really oversimplifying
it
but that was like the bottom line
unifying
motivation behind these openings and the
alakan is one of those openings right
you are literally provoking your
opponent
into controlling a lot of the center and
so that's why i talk about finding a
balance
when you encounter an opening like that
it's not all about grabbing a lot of the
center
we now know that the hyper modernists
were right this is a very legitimate way
of playing
the old school guys were also right it's
good to occupy center with pawns
as usual the truth is somewhere in the
middle i know that's not a very popular
thing to say right now
in general but truth is somewhere in the
middle bishop e3
h3 let's continue the game e5 castles
keeping the tension he goes e4
and he blunders the pawn what should he
have done here he should have also kind
of kept the tension with a move like
bishop f5
by the way if he takes on d4 what
happens in the end is that he has this
pawn on d6 which is super weak
that pawn is going to be easier to
attack if that d-file opens
okay it's going to be easier for us to
pile up on that pawn
eventually and to attack it okay
i take c4 knight back to c3 now the move
rook to c1 preventing his knight from
getting to c2
dropping his knight back he goes knight
c2 not a good move
we trade everything why do we trade
because his knight is his most active
base queen b3
getting our knight to the center now the
move bishop g5 reinforcing the threat of
97 and creating the possibility of
weakening his dark squares
which is exactly what we do now we go
rookie six
it's okay we bring our bishop back
flexible knight g5 a lot of people were
attracted by
this idea right it seems to fork the
king and the rogue but remember
his king could simultaneously defend the
rook and we're only up a pawn
so this would be a little bit
oversimplifying
tranquility asks why not 22 bishop h6
trading off the dark bishops creating
weakness
absolutely viable idea queen d2 would be
i would almost say just as good yeah so
there isn't only one way to play some of
these positions
okay so now we go knight to d2 queen to
a2
that's also a good reason you know
that's not why i played a3
but um it's a good byproduct of that
move and now queen takes d5
creating the threat of bishop h6 he's
already busted here he should have gone
king g7
to at least prevent that threat but now
we would have brought our knight in and
well this is just totally devastating
you mentioned rook c1 was a good move at
some point absolutely thank you for
reminding me
in this position he had a bit of a nasty
move rook c1
sorry not here but here
so the idea is if we take there is a
very specific tactical idea
what is this an undefended piece how
does he exploit it
you guys tell me queen f4 track
yeah very fitting that benny watts got
that benny watts would have seen it
queen f4 check wins the bishop and
there's another problem if we just say
yeah it's fine
we're not going to do anything well
guess what now he drags our king to a
very vulnerable spot
and he delivers a very nasty check on c1
we can defend with 91 but
you guys can see this is a little bit
nasty so
in such a position you have to get to
the bottom of what's causing the issue
what's causing the issue is we can't
take on c1 and we don't want to get our
king to f1
so you got to think logically about what
you have to do there's a couple of good
moves here lang's boo very good movie
shoot g5
this defends the c1 square we could come
at it from that perspective
or we could go knight to d2 in order to
recapture the rook with a knight
that's why you don't want to panic when
you encounter moves like that you just
want to understand why they work what
makes the mechanism run
it's the fact that if our king gets to
f1 and then he goes queen c1
he causes a lot of trouble so we can
either defend the c1 square or we can
make sure that our king remains
safe on g1 does that make sense
and are there any other questions about
this game
okay looks like people are satisfied
yeah queen d3 would be fine queen d3
would be fine but
as i always say if you can fulfill a
task
with a weaker piece do it with that
piece rather than a queen because now
the queen ends up being very passive
and he can slam his queen into c2 and at
least he's got a little bit of activity
this is not a problem
but um you know this would be something
that we would have to deal with
[Music]